what's up guys we're pongfinity today
we're playing table tennis battleships
first one to pop all five balloons wins
let's go
this is the first one
so scary
last time i lost otto yeah but i'm
smarter this time of course it all
worked out
what's that sound
are there any spare balloon because i
think i might
what happened there emil nothing
oh
so
annoying next one you blow up emily
you're not allowed to replace
this is the golden one he will never pop
this one keep your eyes on this one
because this one will make it through
the whole game
oh boy
[Music]
oh boy
this is the golden one never pop this
one
all right so there was a bit of an
accident with the balloon but we're back
on track
okay i hope we are finally ready good
luck emil good luck mikka
oh this is this is always so nervous
this is this is yeah
am i even gonna hit the table
no he didn't hit the table
[Applause]
oh double shot
it sounded like a double
not even close enough
i think it was quite close
how am i not hitting them that was
actually really close was it are you
bluffing or was it i don't know
that was really close
[Music]
how does he know where my ball three
zero
i actually think it's somewhere it's
it's a long one maybe yeah
now let's start popping him
or not
emma do you even have any balls over
there
i might have put some under the table
yes
i got one i had to give him one the
square to ear milk to emil's right right
on the edge
i didn't hit it did i
i feel that it's somewhere there but i
haven't just hit it yet i still think
it's in this corner oh no this one shot
[Music]
who's gonna hit it first
yes
okay you touched it
yeah that was the second time everybody
really
second time why didn't i i get the pop
from the first one already okay you got
that one emma thanks
whoa
three one one more to go i'm pretty sure
it has to be
a short one and i think it's it's on the
right side too
maybe middle shorts
he's maybe onto something
[Music]
no it's not under the table emma it's
got to be long far
[Applause]
no
what happened though
nothing did it touch the villa
okay okay well now i know where it is
not even closer emma
oh okay
now you're hitting that was a jackpot
that was a jackpot
[Music]
it definitely was a jackpot
yeah okay
okay
okay now we're both down to the last
balloon so it's a perfect time for you
guys to hit subscribe
it's down to the final balloon ammo
[Music]
[Applause]
come on
finally i found it
it was somewhere here right this one
okay hope you guys enjoyed this balloon
battle next time it will be me against
otto the winners play against each other
until next time